[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
you can't hear me
hold up
all right trying to talk now
I can hear you
it'd always be like working sometimes
and not working sometimes I have to
figure out exactly how this works
every time
all right talk now
I'm here
all right now I don't know what always
does this like switch you off and on
before I can hear you it's weird all
right so obviously we are back with
another
r r man so what's been going on King
well
Titanfall
I will Titanfall Attack on Titan
straight with it it's starting straight
with it yeah well I mean because that's
that's that's just my journey into uh
the attack on Titan's world
um so I got to the survey team and you
know everybody came over you know it was
one big speech like if you're gonna join
the survey team you gonna die and if you
about that life then you need to ride or
die it was like 100 people strong and
then it was 10.
so
that you know the survey team got over
there they got their little jackets I
mean The Capes The Capes you know don't
disrespect The Capes because the capes
is like the most prestigious thing
hopping so you know everybody see them
walking through the town with the capes
on yo
outside of that wall
it is Buck bananas
yo they go out there and they go out in
the field and they gotta run out in
formations and they got mad formations
they they mad synchronized they got the
whole amen
he said here okay uh shout out to
Sovereign with the 20 Super Chat here's
my obligatory Super Chat so I don't get
shamed for no reason on Sunday now let
me bounce before they spoil episode two
for me
look man we see it looks off because I
know you ain't never here we got a
spoiler room all right so unless it's
red we good unless it's red is green
like static I mean if he watched the
show he would know we got spoilers that
you know it'll pop up but it says
spoilers like that you see you see it
I'm gonna start saying that King unless
it's red it's green basically it's a
gold
all right so you know they they out
there in formations right and they got
the the smoke they shoot the Smoke Out
buddy
these dudes just fighting regular you
know 14 foot uh Titans uh or whatever 14
story Titans those are the small fast
dudes then this dude came out crab style
from behind I ain't gonna built it and
he was chasing old boy on the horse crab
Stout if you don't know what crabs look
like they hunched over and they moved
real fast and he's chasing this dude at
Super top speed and it was bugged out
but um they wind up evading that dude
and then in the distance they see this
big titan that look a little bit
different and it's running at top speed
like faster than the normal Titans
and it's just coming up on them coming
up on them coming up on them and um if
they notice it's a female because some
boys say oh man look at the hips on that
one
to the tank comes running up and it's
really not paying them no mind and I
guess they felt disrespected because the
Titan wasn't even paying these dudes no
mind and he's like yo we're gonna take
them out they went to go take out the
Titan and um they use these these swords
to chop off the neck so when you're out
in the open field it's very hard because
you can't grapple on the buildings
so you have to grab along to the flush
you do grappled onto one piece of the
fish you know how real quick to
interrupt you know how serious you know
that is they they actually have a Titan
Attack on Titan game they have two of
them I gotta play it yeah when you're
using that Oni gear in the fields you
could like you can only like use it on
One Tree at a time so you have to like
shoot yourself as far as you can hoping
you could grab another tree and it's
rough like those horses are very vital
to their survival but they they said
they said it they was like
um you know make sure you got you stay
on the host because Aaron fell off the
horse but
they go up against the Titan and he
tried to smack him in the neck and he
blocked it like
and then
knocked the dude off his horse and
smashed him on the floor and just kept
moving didn't need him okay
all right iron Lords podcast again 20
Super Chat just remember the rest of the
Lords are not allowed to have their own
opinions on movies unless you watch R
and R so here's my obligatory Super Chat
so I don't get abused as the host of IOP
wow you know what's going on they're
talking to you on the phone right now
okay you do it first and then I'll do it
next and I come right behind and pause
Hollywood rules at least they know the
rules when it comes to movies if you
ain't on the show your opinion don't
matter exactly exactly did you hear that
y'all
uh Hollywood rules is the two dollar
Super Chat thank you brother my boys
keep doing your thing last of us so far
that's right love for the last of us is
definitely dope
yeah we'll get today here
momentarily so okay Aaron's on the floor
I'm gonna get to that I'm just gonna get
to the quick part Aaron's on the floor
and a Titan does some different crap
grabs this little hoodie and like lifts
it just a little bit would you imagine
King Kong just grabbing your hoodie to
peek and see your face who you are and
you ain't the person he's looking for he
just ah yeah and that's the first time
in the show that the Titans show some
form tell intelligence and but that's
not they're like oh that's the reason
that Aaron had uh that Arwen had
everyone put their Hood over because
that Titan's looking for Aaron exactly
but see let me let me tell you that's
not the first time because the other
skin and bone Titan
the one that they was trying to kill
they wanted to just disappeared like
that yeah yeah the tall one the very
tall one I'm very curious like
once you get to like uh you're about to
get to the point where I would say it's
a hard stop and then we'll start doing
the the back end stuff that we have
planned yeah because uh I want your I I
think people are going to want to see
your general
Impressions on what happens in this
force that you're about to come up on
okay so yeah because we're gonna um
we're gonna be doing a uh patreon stuff
and other channel stuff and we'll let
y'all know exactly to see the live
reactions because I'm gonna watch the
show live for you guys and y'all can get
my reactions when I'm screaming and
yelling and you know and all types of
stuff but um
so addict I I I popped into your DMs and
I was like yo
check out this show because I'm trying
to educate attic on superhero stuff okay
hold up hold up hold up so so are we
officially moving on to uh yeah that's
that's my Attack on Titan I'm outside
the wall I'm in the survey team
they got their hoodies on and we find
out that there's female Titans with nice
hips running around uh peeking into
people's hoodies
all right so just uh okay clarify we're
going to the Super one right yeah so
we're going to uh Battle of the super
Sons
all right so I I did watch uh super Suns
uh how exactly do they want me to to is
it Battle of the super okay first off
you know I didn't know Superman had a
kid I'll be real yeah I didn't know that
so explain to me about Superman having a
kid first like what's the origins behind
this this this Batman first of all I
didn't know Batman had a kid either so
you know I'm gonna point that out too uh
so what's the origins behind all this
okay so Batman he didn't even know he
had a son uh he had a son with Raaz al
Ghul's daughter
what she did was um she she like
tranquilized him whatever took his you
know she raped basically raped that man
right got his baby
and her and razaku raised him
but she didn't like what Raju was trying
to do because razaku was trying to have
him uh become the leader of the clan
told him how to kill and all this other
stuff and you know um she wanted more
for her son so she you know contacted
Batman told Batman and he had a son and
dropped him off like here after the kid
is like uh 13 14 years old you know
here's your son and he's having a hard
time adjusting to you know uh being in
confinement
um
he's he's like a boss he's the most
dangerous Robin
that ever was you know what I like there
was a part where uh an individual jumped
on you know where I get into the spoiler
thing yeah uh but they they jumped on
this Jet and Rob is like what are you
doing just kill her
and that's what I like about him because
he's not like uh Dick Grayson he's not
like Jason Todd Jason Todd had all of
bravado but none of the training right
uh Dick Grayson has all the training but
no bravado
right so now you have
um Damon
Damon is a different animal within
himself because he's better than Batman
right let's let's be real he's better
than Batman but he's just in a little
tiny shell so if he was Batman's age and
height and weight I think he can beat
Batman but um and Superman's son he had
it with Lois Lane Lois Lane that's John
Ken uh and I think that the smartest
thing that DC did was give Batman a son
a biological son so he can stop going
around grabbing these orphans up with
these little boys and stuff like that
because I didn't think it played well
with modern times now right because yeah
in in the in the in the books back in
the days it's like oh he got an orphan
and you know did Grace and his family
died let me take this kid but then you
you put him in a child endangerment
basically have him out there fighting
criminals so this is his kid and he's
the most trained uh Robin is now
Superman's son what you've seen in this
movie is uh you know he was born his
powers didn't manifest himself because
they didn't know if it would manifest
itself or if it wouldn't but over a
period of time his body absorbed uh
raised from the sun because they're like
little batteries you know kryptonians
and his powers were manifesting through
trauma so through trauma it evoked his
powers like you know kind of like
mutants in the Marvel universe so um you
saw him get the heat vision first and
then he got the super strength and he
still has doesn't have the ability of
flight yet in this series yeah in this
movie there's a time uh you know towards
the end uh
portion of the movie so I got something
for he's like what he pushes the ball
he's like still can't fly
it's like he takes like enjoyment out of
being able to do stuff that his dad
can't do to the real Superman because
exactly he put if first off he couldn't
push the real Superman but do you notice
how like it's so funny
Batman's son likes Superman and
Superman's son likes Batman and you know
it's just so it's just so weird you know
so
um but they have a nice camaraderie
because in the movie you get a chance to
see Batman and Superman talk about their
children and raising a son and how hard
it is and you can see two different
styles in parenting excuse me where
Batman is a little rough
but uh Superman is a lot more gentle
right and Superman is a stronger one so
he has to learn how to be more gentle
with his son because he's going to
probably inherit the same powers that he
has Batman has to be a little bit more
rough with his son because of his
upbringing and the fact that he doesn't
have these superpowers to fall back on
and he wants them to be prepared for
whatever the world is going to bring him
so it's two different parenting Styles
and but they both love their kids they
both love the hell out of the kids and I
like this movie do you want to go ahead
and get into the spoiler part of it yeah
guys we're going to get into the spoiler
portion remember now this is a battle of
the super Sons it's showing on HBO Max
now uh so you can go check that out on
HBO Max it's something really dope if
you're into animation I think uh Warner
Brothers uh DC animations they do the
best cartoons I don't know why they
can't translate it to their movies but
they definitely Lee translated well in
the cartoons so I actually watched this
a lot of Grace Grace is actually because
I was like on and off the first time I
watched it I had to like go back and
re-watch it but she was more into it
than I was because I said I can't watch
this I'm half asleep she's like no I
want to finish it though like so you
know I really I like the fact that like
you know it kind of makes more sense
that to me that Batman would have a kid
I didn't even know Superman had a kid in
comics or anything like that like so
it's interesting that like his powers
keep evolving throughout the movie like
and it's like
one of the the aspects that I really
enjoyed about this game this movie is
there was a part in the movie where
they're fighting each other's fathers
right and they had to switch it up and
and uh super uh Superman's kids like yo
let's just switch and I have to respect
Damian I think that's his name Damien
dami was like I fight Superman that's
fine but we gotta jump my dad real quick
like there was no hesitation there was
no I don't know that's Superman's like
oh that's fine we just gotta go get
something real quick we gotta go beat my
pops up because he has that uh the
contingency plan yo you know what I like
the moment we gotta go visit my dad real
quick I knew what he was getting
yo yo I like when he got into the space
station
and they were looking for the the
anomaly
and they opened the doors and all the
the Justice League and the Teen Titans
well the ones that were there like green
arrow Martin Martian Manhunter Kid Flash
and uh
when you could tell that Daniel was way
more aware of what was going on than the
than the kid Superman like oh yeah
it it leads to Big City uh versus a
small country you know it's
he's more he's a little bit more sharp
and things to pick up and detective work
and stuff like that because of of his
upbringing and and John Kent uh his name
after the grandfather Superman's uh
Sarah Grant uh father surrogate father
he he's uh baseball he goes to school
he's a normal kid
you know and he wants he he doesn't even
know as soon as the movie starts that
his father is Superman he saw the cape
and in the super uh in the costume under
the bed he's like oh what are they into
cosplay
yo Jimmy Olsen is black
um that was a a different take on Jimmy
Olsen because when uh Lois Lane runs up
on Jimmy Olsen she's like yo open your
mouth
yeah it's kind of crazy that his mom
like I didn't
his mom is um what's the chick that the
lowest is that the same like but she is
way more extra in this movie than I've
ever seen here in anything like she
walked out unoriented yeah she she
burped him and she's like she's like
they're weak to fire honey burn they ass
I was like gee well I'm kind of curious
is how did her parents like come out so
naturally than the other ones did
that her parents no her parasite when
they burnt her on the door her parents
had just came straight out why didn't
all the other ones come out like that
because when they burnt some of the
numbers she went under the water
so I think it was damaged and again
breathe or something yeah so that's the
only thing I can come up with I mean but
it was a plot point
it wasn't a big plot point though like
you know I really enjoyed you know just
first off it's animation I feel like
this type of storytelling's done better
in animation yeah and uh I I really
enjoyed it I I enjoyed when they fought
the uh the Justice League or I don't
know if that was the joke it was a
Justice League slash Teen Titans uh two
Teen Titans there and you had two
Justice League members there and they
couldn't have even though he had some of
his dad's Powers Yeah they could have
won that without Dan uh without uh I
forget his name Damien because
Damien knew their weaknesses yeah
Damon's a tactician yeah
he was fighting them for their
weaknesses yeah and he's Batman little
Batman and you could tell that the the
kid the Superman kid he wasn't about
that life he was he was winging it like
all winging it like learning it on it
was funny that they shot him to the uh
the space Observatory uh in Superman's
original uh rocket that he came to Earth
in
that was crazy it was all cramped up and
then he found his his baby uh blanket
and he said
as a cape and he's like yo it looks dope
don't it and Damon's like nah not not
not really not at all that's why I have
to you know hat off to this movie uh you
know I I I liked it man I liked it but
what's the popcorn writing man
I have to say four two I have to say
yeah but four right I just felt like it
was a phenomenal movie it was it was it
was dope it was dope the animation was
dope so remember
um the star the star creature was in the
live movie adaptation of uh um Suicide
Squad 2. right and my wife even said
this was a better take on that creature
and in in the movie Suicide Squad 2 it
was just dorky she said and it didn't
come off like a real threat and it just
it felt like they would be able to fix
it but this one
they really showed how uh dangerous the
threat was and how it can hide in plain
sight because in the movie it was all on
the face at all times in this uh
animation
it hides in their mouth and then it
Burrows out right before it's about to
attack or whatever to see things so so I
think this is well done is that thing
like real in the actual yeah in the
comic books yeah
all right so I I didn't know that but
yeah I I liked it I thought it was a
solid thing I think people should
definitely go check it out especially if
you are I mean we we didn't really say
the good thing about spoiling something
like this if people showed up you know
towards the end is even though that we
spot some of the plots in the movie it's
still worth a watch like just yeah which
is how they do things too much yeah but
it's still worth a watch man it's still
worth it definitely
all right so
King I I sent you
on a a homework assignment okay kind of
like what you did to me with that last
movie I'm like yo you know check this
movie out man check this movie out uh
what what was that movie what was that
movie sick
yeah so we we watched sick I watched it
last week and you know I was sitting in
there at my girl's place and I was
looking for something because she was at
work and I was like what what kind of
something I could watch and I saw this
movie on peacock it was called sick
yeah it's a peacock origin I don't know
if that means like it would ever go
anywhere because you know sometimes
certain things just it's an original
because they made a deal so you know
right now you can only watch this on
peacock and pretty much what it is it's
like
it's kind of those things that you would
see off of something such as
we all knew when we was going into they
were going to make movies about the
pandemic we knew it was going to happen
oh God and this movie is very centered
around the pandemic but they don't throw
in your face and I think you can agree
King
you know the the the the settings
and a lot of the plot has to do with the
pandemic but once you get past the stuff
they do to open that up I'm wanting to
say that this movie does a very good job
at separating itself from the pandemic
to a point
where you don't even know this is about
the pandemic anymore like no I was I was
keenly aware throughout the whole film
that this was a pandemic film
[Music]
um
in the sense they were told to
quarantine
excuse me and that's the reason why
they're in this cabin
um
social media plays a big thing yeah
it's it's this I remember movies
oh no no we didn't get there this movie
is so topical so current so now
I mean from the vernacular of the
characters
um from the you know the actors
um from the scenery uh from the
technology that they're using uh
everything about it was current it felt
now it didn't feel like uh it was excuse
me
displaced out of time or anything it was
very very current so um
I was like okay and I'm gonna see how
it's gonna work how they're going to use
technology with it
how they're going to use what's topical
as far as the pandemic goes
um
and it weaves its way into the story
in a way that it's not so intrusive like
you said but it's it's it's on the film
and and you get a sense of okay this is
the reason why they're on this Lake
by themselves
right so you got a reason why they're
isolated you have a reason why this
movie is in this setting what what I
liked about it is like I said the reason
I think it's it does a good job by
stating this is a pandemic movie but
then about 10 minutes into it after
they've established like it's the
beginning of the pandemic you've got to
isolate yourself yeah you kind of forget
about that for like half the movie yeah
because pretty much it's like the movies
generally like a scream without the
comedy it's like someone's in the house
huh I said boy you hit the nail on the
head yeah so someone's someone's in the
house someone is is doing some suspect
stuff that's pretty much what the
movie's about and I I think they do a
good job at really building up
anticipation of what is actually going
on uh so you know it is so what what was
your overall perspective when you saw
like just the trailer or not even
trailer just first five ten minutes I
don't know if you watch the trailer
because I usually watch a trailer before
I pop in them no I I don't watch the
trailer
um on something that you know like if
it's an assignment something I gotta
watch I just go into it right I go into
it blind not knowing what's going on um
the first 10 minutes
somebody's getting murdered yeah they
actually they do
they do a really good job at like just
kicking the door open and it's crazy you
know you want you you want to just go
ahead and get straight in to this well I
mean start off with a spoiler so yeah
let's go straight into the spoiler man
let's go first 10 minutes it's crazy
because you have no idea why
right okay
guys in the supermarket
he gets a text message
so this is where they use technology at
right they're using the technology
um and it's like nice butt
what he thinks it's a joke he's looking
around like yeah first no it says
something stupid the first one it said
uh you wanna You Wanna Party or
something do you want to party
and you know he's like man who the hell
is this this misses it or automatically
and then he's in line they take a
picture of his butt and says nice butt
so he's looking around paranoid like who
the hell
it's here he doesn't recognize nobody
behind him
here's my question to you King yeah
let's say you at the store and you get a
message saying nice butt are you gonna
take it as well as he did where he
didn't really question anything didn't
look around really like he just did like
well you gotta look at the Statue of the
kid
he wasn't a a demonstrative dude he was
diminutive dude you know
um
he didn't look like he's into any
confrontational uh type of aspect so me
personally I'm gonna count how many
peoples on the line
then I'm going to judge the distance in
the shot I'm smacking this the dog fire
whoever is in that distance that I think
you went I think it was one of those
things where he the individual took the
picture and then left the scene like I
don't know if somebody would have just
got smacked for no reason because it's
absolutely no way you're gonna take a
picture of my butt and say nice
walk up and just
like it's like one of those things where
they're sitting there like
that's all right let me see your phone
let me see your phone I'm gonna take
something
no I'm gonna say when a when a male
Karen goes crazy let me see your phone
cop car he put why did you do it he took
a picture of my behind there you go but
check it out at it I wouldn't die
so okay so get it so the dude leaves out
of there he gets in his car he goes home
and when he gets into the house he hears
like a car alarm
and then uh he got another text message
or something
yeah I can't remember what that text
message said but there was definitely
another text message he got another text
message and he looks out his door but he
turns back as he hears something outside
the window and then you see somebody
walk in the background in this house
we're all black
I'm like oh this is real real
this this oh okay he's in danger
to do without any hesitation pulls out a
butcher knife that's like Yay big Mario
that we fight with like you really
seriously couldn't fight with that nah
but he was abnormally strong
he's slamming this guy all over the
place look in the picture we've
displayed for the chat like this is the
size of a Butch it's like a Michael
Myers butcher knife yeah it don't make
no sense it doesn't make any sense you
would you would hurt yourself quicker
than you would hurt them with that thing
at some point in time it's gonna you
know you're gonna get tired swinging
this this big butcher knife
yo he fights this guy man they do all
types of things and it was a point where
he could have ran out the house
this idiot stays in the house
yeah he should have he should have left
that that's where you see like little
holes were realistically a human being
would have left the house yeah and it
because they I mean I guess
obviously
you know we are in the spoiler thing
because I'm about to spoil a big portion
of the movie
there was more to going on than just
that individual there was actually oh
yeah two killers and yeah I didn't know
that though I thought it was one dude
getting busy I didn't I didn't know that
at that time you know when I knew there
was two killers when when they threw
homegirl off the top of the balcony and
when she went to the bottom the killer
was already there coming in the front
door I was like there's no way there's
no way you can move that fast no no no
at that point I still thought it was
Supernatural stuff
because he was abnormally strong when he
threw homeboy up against the wall yeah
yeah and then he had him up on a pipe I
don't like this concept when we're doing
like the these like slasher things where
one person and they they as a group it
don't matter if that's a man as a group
those two chicks and that third dude
because we didn't know about the second
dude at the time what a body that dude
like whatever you bodied him at it all
right so all right okay so let's get
let's all right so this guy dies right
he he gets scared yeah why I just
skipped like huge portions he he slashes
to do next so cut to two girls two girls
uh are going to quarantine together and
they get over to the cabin because this
is our family's cabin
what I noticed off the rip there's a
very huge lack of security yeah it was
it was it was kind of bad and you know I
felt like the chicks too was a little
bit like naive they they didn't not the
black one the black one was jumpy and
scared of everything you know yeah but I
don't think that's
that's any form of like I think that's a
lot of like you know just her anxiety
coming off like and the other two did
not care the other chick did not care
once about anything but then okay so the
new DJ shows up
DJ shows up because DJ think they have a
thing but she's using DJ as a little you
know little boy side piece that that it
does seem like she did get a little too
close to the star
she was she was she was feeling herself
she goes and she does a video
of her kissing a whole bunch of boys at
this party
and I guess the the video goes viral I
guess it goes viral for some reason I
have no clue why that video would go
live it wasn't nothing big but I guess
for the pandemic you're going around
kissing people in this corner yeah you
think about it that direction yeah yeah
it was like you know pandarin F the
pandemic covet's not real Sy and Z blah
blah blah
but she really put it up to hurt this
dude to hurt his feelings
because he wanted to make it something
more and she wanted to show him
that we're not serious we're just this
is just a fling thing
and her inadvertently trying to hurt and
be malicious to this kid who actually
cared about it because he drove all the
way up there to see her and he's like yo
you know what's up what's going on when
you know let's get down to the
conversation
she basically dismissed them and and and
you know like you know kicked him to the
side but that's when everything kicks
off that's when the killer comes
gets into the house nobody sees him when
he gets in you know you do see him if
you really pay attention when he goes
out to the truck oh yeah they don't see
him yeah they don't see him we see him
so pretty much what happened is uh the
chick ends up fight they uh one of them
goes to bed first and then the the chick
that is leading on the other dude she
goes to bed so it's just this dude he
he's upset so he goes out to his car and
when he opens the door because you got
to consider the doors here and the door
to the house is on the other side so he
doesn't have visible sight on the house
at this point because he's looking
inside there's a door between him and
the front door the killer comes around
that front side and goes straight in you
see it but they don't like it nice and
quiet
yo this guy is crazy so he goes inside
the house
the homeboy you know falls asleep on the
couch
this is where it turns into 2023 stuff
this killer takes the time
not kill them
he goes and takes this cell he goes to
each and every last one of them and
somehow none of them woke up none of
what the dude woke up take this up but
he woke up because uh he wanted to use
his phone or whatever
because you know we're addicted to these
stupid gadgets so he gets up to reach
for his phone his phone is missing
and then when he stands up
there's loud music playing yeah and then
and then keep in mind it just pans away
from that you don't see this dude for a
couple minutes so yeah your your mind is
set something's about to happen here I
could see then it pans straight to the
chick that's leading them on and what I
like about it is they threw me off guard
for a second I thought she was gonna
come out there see him stab maybe see
him dead or something related to that
but she walks through the stairs she
looks down and he shows up and puts his
hand over her mouth and says there's
someone in the house and I'm like yo it
caught me off guard because they don't
normally do that King they don't
normally let the other people know
what's going on
so that part happens
and he says we got to go get the other
girl
then the killer pops up
the killer pops up at this point
I'm like jumping in my head that's what
I'm saying like this
at this point okay let's put it to you
guys this way okay here's the house
she is outside the house so the White
Chicks outside the house the black chick
is in the bed and the Killer's coming to
her in the bed so you know it would take
a couple seconds for that white chick to
get around but she could but okay so
he's about to kill the black chick
homeboy just comes out of nowhere and
slides against the wall and then he
tells her to run I'm like no no if the
black chicken that dude would have
teamed up that dude would have been out
of there they would have killed him
right there easy because the dude was
giving him that business King in the
beginning when he had the strength when
he had the strength
that's what I like when when they make
the killers
defeatable because you see it in the
screen movies you see it in some other
movies but there's some times where you
can't do nothing to those killers they
just gonna walk through everything but
man they they were messing this dude up
multiple times like multiple times every
one of the main
uh every one of the main uh protagonists
in this movie there was three of them
messed up these killers at least once to
twice
yo what I liked is when um when he was
fighting the Killer
it was a moment he fought him too long
by himself
and he was he he just got attacked
because remember they were smoking
earlier they were drinking earlier
so they probably still have all his
friends still half asleep to some degree
basically
so this guy picks him he's got a journey
on the running through him so he's he's
wasting more energy than you would think
normally the guy picks him up turns him
sideways and
smashes them against the wall
then he wraps into the blanket
and he starts going into that town on
that blanket stabbing that blanket up
yeah and all I can think is
while those two chicks is sitting in the
car this dude's getting killed he's
getting y'all could have jumped this
dude all three of y'all could have
played but feet pulling the fair at the
time we thought it was one person so
yeah but I mean they could have still
killed the dude yeah and then okay
asking you a question how well do you
think they hit the second person
very well I didn't expect it so I when I
started assuming it's like I said that
there was a time where the where the
dude's dead he he he he he was ran
through with some like some sharp object
so he's dead he's gone and then the
chick he they start chasing the chick
everywhere the chick the the women
everywhere so they get to this this
addict and first off that door looks
strong he wasn't breaking in that door
that easy
when they bust into the door
and they kicked them down
I said jump them
yo it was multiple instances in this
movie
they could have jumped there was a time
where the dude literally had him on the
ground it was over a rap but he
surprised him with the knife and stabbed
him like if if that dude was alive they
could have easily have killed them maybe
even both of them because you know as
you will find out we'll get to that here
in a second you know
so after they get that they the the two
women are on the rooftops they're going
through the rooftops and then he grabs
him he grabs the black chicks through
the window which I will agree with you
he did grab her like a ragdoll and you
know at first I thought he threw
something out the window to break it but
if you go back and look he's literally
smashes his hands through the window
which isn't really realistic but he's
this is where I'm pissed off right I'm
pissed off at that point where she has
Leverage
if she holds on to him
she could yank him out the window
right if she falls back
she can take him out the window
either way
both of us is hitting out of this window
yeah I hated the fact that I knew when
it was going past the window
somebody gonna get grabbed yeah
and I could tell it wasn't the first
chick because she she was quick going
through because you can tell this chick
was some sneaky chick when she was
younger man she was going around this
rooftop like it was nothing like she
done stuck out of her house a thousand
times when she was a teenager and what
was funny is so they threw the the black
chick off she's on the ground so I I
kind of didn't think look she looked
like Family Guy yeah I didn't think she
was dead I I at that time no there was
no way she was dead so I'm sitting there
and I'm like all right so
the white chick comes down keep in mind
that we're talking
10 15 seconds
and she's going out the front door
thinking she fine because
homegirl was just throwing out the
window on like a four-story house yeah
so The Killers upstairs she opens the
front door the kill is coming through
the front door I was like that's two
killers
[Laughter]
all right so at this point
found out it was two people I'm thinking
he's still Supernatural
I said your man's Supernatural
so she's fighting this dude and she
whoops his ass she Molly wops him
but again I say it again
excuse me
she don't kill this dude I'm like you
banging him in the head between bang
them in the neck
I got no I gotta defend homegirl right I
can I am convinced she thought he was
dead because there's a time where she
stops and he's bleeding and she just
keeps going back to town right like I
feel it but I think the reason she
stopped hitting him is because at that
time that's when the second individual
came through the door
no no no remember
she stopped and she takes a breath
and she's like
okay
and she's like um
let me agree she didn't serious damage
she did but she was like normally I'd be
with you I'll be like yo they should
have kept hitting him but if I was I
probably would have thought he was dead
I would have cut his throat I'm sorry
what actually happens to him like no
listen it's a body here already I just
gotta make sure I gotta have confirmed
kill you understand what I'm saying I
watched too many movies not to have
confirmed kill I'm gonna have to cut his
car on it but I mean anyway she goes
outside to go check on her friend
because she figured she got the monster
I got the monster
and she goes and then she hears the guy
go inside the door and he goes oh no no
no no no what happened
what happened when when she stopped and
she put down the it was like some some
uh some some utensil used in in the
kitchen that she killed him yeah well
she beat the [__] out of him with so she
puts it down and she looks up and
there's another individual mask that's
coming through the door yeah so at this
point
she's like it's over it's a wrap like
because and you know what's funny is at
this time the black chick is still on
the ground outside and the other dude's
just dead he's the he's not coming back
he's dead Okay so Eddie all right all
right so the hell that so the next
killer
tracking of fighting her tracking of
fighting her
she gets to the road
fighting on the road and she see a car
in the distance coming up the road
I'm like yeah she gonna get out of here
why the hell she get to the car and the
lady go oh what's going on
chicken
that that is where I said they did a
good job taking you away from the
pandemic the whole point of the movie
because at that point when she's talking
about oh honey do you put your mask on I
forgot this is a panda movie now what
she said when she bleeding out and she
go where your mask at
is
so like there was some loopholes in this
movie but I I do think
that it wasn't significant enough to
make me not enjoy the movie because
sometimes you'd be looking at something
like come on man we know that's not how
that would work but get it so get it so
the lady goes she pulls out a plastic oh
I got an extra one here she slips she
slips it through the top of the window
put it on she's like come on give me the
goddamn a message she put the mask on
and she jump in the car and she goes
this man smells like
so how the hell you know what chloroform
smell like it's a question question
when she got in that car
did you suspect that she was with the
killers no no dude I thought
I didn't either I didn't expect she was
The Killers I thought she was good when
when you when she had like when they
didn't pan out her driving the moment
she got in the car that's when I started
suspecting stuff because like why ain't
you driving like the moment she was in
that car I think they picked that lady
purposely because
oh for me
that Lady represents nice she's always
been nice in every film that I've ever
seen she's never played a villain she's
she's she's she's such a great actress
she's always been the nice quiet you
know I'm thinking this is all right you
find you made it to the lady that's on
TV that's nice girl all right
yeah she played the wickedest evilest
woman that you know when they get to the
house
and she's talking to her husband here's
the question should we ruin the whole
objective of the movie of what
everything no no you know what nah nah
I'm gonna tell you we will let you guys
find out why these two individuals going
around causing Havoc we'll let you find
that out by yourself huge plot twist it
was a good twist though King it's it's
yo it's all self-inflicted this whole
movie is self-inflicted
you don't think so
uh I feel like I feel like that's grief
like no I feel like no I'm talking about
if one person didn't do one thing yeah
no I I know what you're saying but I
don't feel what the people did was
justification for what they were doing
like because you could you could have
literally connected the dots like a
thousand different other ways of how
that individual ended up coming up with
the situation yeah yeah and that that's
what I'm saying like it was grief they
wanted to pin this on the first person
they could pin it on well isn't that how
everything goes it is it is
you know um it's it's how you deal with
loss and
they man
they they really went the the sick way
with it that's why it's called sick they
really with the sick way with how they
dealt with loss and I mean this is what
happens when people take their own
manners into their own hands and you
don't you don't rationally think about
things I mean the movie has a deeper
meaning and it's it's it does good in
that part but let's let's get to the
rating on this movie
okay
so um
I went first last time you go first
system
I kind of spoiled it because I went
first remember oh okay then I'll go
first this time yeah I'm gonna give it a
three star three pop me too yeah I was
gonna give it a three star because of
all the plot holes yeah it was a solid
movie it's definitely worth watching
especially if you have peacock now is
this worth buying peacock for no no yeah
I wouldn't say that I mean if you get
the trial you know you want to sit there
uh the re the reason I do recommend it's
like it it it's a good couple movie too
yeah so you can watch this and I feel
like unless
your significant other has like a
completely different Taste of movies I
think both you would enjoy it
it's something that you're both like
it's funny as hell
yes and then you start to laugh at stuff
that you would have did uh you know
differently when it comes to it
it's a king
all we down to the to the main event
we we are down to the main event today
we will be talking about episode two
episode two of the one and only Last of
Us HBO show so King King first off you
know
We're not gonna go too much into no the
the episode uh I feel like with these
you know we'll
we'll go into a little bit
but at the end of the day I I recommend
first off let's let's go me and you do
you recommend this show off two episodes
so far oh hell yeah yes I I do too it's
it's a phenomenal show
um you know considering you some of you
know I'm sure most of you know us coming
from the iron Lords podcast we we
primarily talk about games that's why
sometimes you when I'm talking about a
movie sometimes I'll say game by
accident because I'm so used to talking
about games but
the accuracy in this show on the game
just shows everyone else you can do this
you don't have to do anything different
what
the original
the original script is good enough to
satisfy everyone so you know look what
what is some of your highlights with
because we are gonna have a spoiler
thing but I do want to talk about your
general expectations with this episode
and the highlights that you did have
with without spoiling anything okay well
as soon as the episode started I saw
that Neil druckman directed this one
and I said okay I want to uh see exactly
how he's going to add more uh more sauce
to already a good uh mix
more layers to a a deeper onion I wanted
to see deeper into the mind of of the
Greek meal uh drugman
and
he just he didn't disappoint at all at
all
um
it this is not a spoiler I saw a tick
tock video of him on the scene with the
actual director the person who directs
the majority of the of the episodes and
nailed showing him where the clickers
need to come out
yeah
it's his level of care for his product
his his baby
it shows
um
the Clickers
see we we saw infected
this is the first time we heard that
I actually I looked up a picture the
best picture I cut I don't uh it said
this came from the TV show but
man
we gotta be honest man they did a good
job with how the clickers look how they
interact perfectly uh one thing I will
bring up you know is I do feel like the
human interaction needs bit needs more
so far like and we got to get to the
point too where a lot of the human
interactions in the game was solely just
for gameplay they had no purpose
whatsoever in the actual shooting or
anything like that but it does make me
think that are
is HBO
in Sony because we know that when you
look at the gaming portion you know Sony
has came back a little bit on like
killing humans right now it's
interesting that every time they come
across humans that are dead
they got they died off screen right so I
I don't know if that's how the story is
written I don't know if they don't want
to go like showing uh humans getting
killed on screen but to me
it's like I do want a balance of
infected and human interaction because
that's what the Last of Us was about
I think as the series go on and as uh
Ellie and Joe
uh start to uh
get a deep understanding of each other I
think that we'll see that when they
start to talk to other humans
um
but at the moment it's still World
building it's still World crafting
because remember they're explaining how
they had to bomb the place
yeah and and they spoke to the
Indonesian botanists
and she explained that this is no hope
you know um you know take me holding my
family I I want to go to my family
and just blow this blow this up
um
I was like Wow because she started to
cry
and she looks over at the the officer
and she's
she's like this is very serious right
here and you're gonna have to blow this
place up but um
there's nothing you can do
yeah someone then said uh Sarah
literally got shot by a person uh but
there wasn't a lot of blood in that
scene it was dark you couldn't really
see exactly what happened you just knew
that she got shot uh but
when these infected are going at people
or when you're getting shot by these
fully automatic weapons like in the way
that The Last of Us portrays it in the
actual show there would be a lot of Gore
so but I'm curious that they're not
doing a lot of the human on human
interaction because they want to limit
some of the gore
you'll get a different rating you'll get
a rated R rating
what is this thing rated I think it's
rated PG-13
or uh t t v m a or something but not
rated R I don't believe
is the TMA like worse though it's like
nudity in TMA didn't it uh I don't well
they had nudity there with the lady on
the table
yeah that that kind of actually
surprised me yeah
they could eventually have avoided that
if they wanted to yeah they didn't they
didn't make it let her be let her be
spread eagle just sit right there there
it is we outside
that scene has started off I told my
wife I said okay throw him in the bushes
we all thought but um
this this episode showed me because it
was a couple of things that Neil did
that was different and I and I had to
run to go play the video game and see if
this happened because I forgot
and he added certain things to it
um
I really thought
the Ellie character
you got a chance to see
her age
you got a chance to see a little bit
more into her personality
but you also
understood
that Joel is not a good person he's not
he has done bad
and you know this girl told them
do this do this for me I don't ask you
for a damn thing
do this for me so you can set this right
so you can do this so we can get some
type of piece on this Earth if this
fixes all the crap that we did
do this for me
we got Tyler Crosby what's up Tyler with
the five dollar Super Chat this show
isn't is incredible two episodes in it
might be the best show on right now and
the clickers look amazing this is how
you do a video game show a video game
shows right
definitely 100 I agree with it I agree
with
you can add things to the mail
like the video game
had to tell it in a certain way
and it had to add gameplay elements in
it so now you got to tell the same story
but without the gameplay element so you
have to add extra things to it in order
for you to be able to digest it in the
manner that they want to give it to you
and I believe
I I see how they're doing it and they're
doing it in a master class way you know
um two episodes in
I feel that they they it's it's going to
be probably
and I'm glad they did it this way
instead of doing a movie you understand
because if they did a movie
we wouldn't get all this development all
this good Rich story you know a movie
wouldn't do it justice I think this TV
show does it justice because you're able
to digest it in an hour and a half shows
uh a 45 minute show the hour show so I I
think it it works itself well in how
it's being told
all right so I guess we'll go to the
spoiler portion of the podcast
all right guys so if you did not see
this episode and this is the part where
we're going to spoil a couple of things
we're not going to spoil the whole
episode but this is the part where we're
going to spoil some of the big big plot
points and um
you might want to
walk out the door don't say I didn't
warn you I think what we should stay
away from is the ending the transaction
happened at the end you know we could
talk about it but don't say that
transaction you know what I'm saying
okay
uh it's like the only issue I have is
the lack of humans uh that's all I feel
like everything else they did on point
um I'm starting to come a little bit
more on Ellie uh Bello I think that's
her name playing yeah Ellie I still
don't look her her I don't like her
visualization I I think that's a very
key point to find someone that looks the
part and I don't think she looks the
part I mean but
I gotta say to uh Teresa uh what's her
name again yeah Teresa spot on
like you know she was perfect yeah I was
going on I was looking at like that
ending scene yeah
from side by side it was almost word for
word and it was it's good man and it's
just like something like you see like
this how well the pacing is
a question for you did the kiss happen
in the game
no I don't think it did they didn't yeah
so little things like that that happened
I feel like they wanted I feel like in
the game
they kind of they they kind of worded
them more of like you know we're not a
couple we don't really have feelings
with each other like we're just in this
together you know what I'm saying but in
the in the show it seems like
they try to put more emotion behind them
too because if you notice no I've never
talking about the kiss between her and
Joe
uh who are you talking about you know
what I'm talking about I'm talking about
the the kiss that happened
um
right before the The Joint ends the
climactic uh ending the climax to it
because that's what I'm talking about
okay she okay so you're talking about
all right this this I don't really want
to use it just said
When does the when when the infected
kiss turn them out
oh no
that didn't happen that definitely
didn't happen right so I I was I was
taken aback by this whole situation here
I didn't know why I don't know I didn't
see that as a kiss though I think that's
the reason I'm confused when people
bring that up I saw that as
that individ that that infection
trying to infect her but she was
infected already but then why why would
they even go after at that point then
this is what I'm saying because that's
they were running past her they weren't
paying her any mind
right but Neil decided that this scene
was necessary
in in this manner
to convey something
because she was still fighting the
control of the the parasite because
remember once it starts taking over your
neurological system it starts to command
you to do whatever it wants just like
the ants
but she was still fighting because she
was trying to achieve her goal I think
and this is just my hypothesis of of the
situation
is that
it knew what she was trying to do
because remember they're linked mentally
and she still had a semblance of her
human self
and she was trying to destroy
their chances of of stopping Joe
and it was if if it affected her in that
manner it would take faster
I feel you but I feel like it probably
would have been simpler just to injure
her than it would be to to stop right
I don't know part of me feels like that
is weird I saw it as
I'm infecting you like I right you know
because because I want to have nail on
so bad on IOP to ask him
that question because he directly
directed this episode so he had Direct
input
in putting this scene here which wasn't
in the game
which was an added layer but I wanted to
know I want to know
what was he trying to get across to the
to to to his audience
at this for this specific scene
everything else is fine I just
questioned
this one scene yeah and another thing
too it was you know
they did change up the story just a tad
bit like nothing that would change the
overall aspect of the story if I
remember correctly it's been years since
I played last of us but the reason that
she stayed behind was because human
soldiers in the original game right and
here it was because it's because the
infected uh the whole all the fungus are
connected that's not in the game for all
you know for for what I remember no uh
so it's interesting like I said they're
taking the human aspect out like I just
well we we have to wait until we see I
know encampments and the settlements uh
across the land that while they're
trying to make their way to the
fireflies because you remember the
fireflies
um was killed and the the the the the
thought
that Joel had was
that they turned on each other because
of an infected one got infected um
is it possible
Maybe not maybe maybe so so
um
we just have to see as it as it plays
itself out but I think we're going to
when they start reaching the smaller
encampments of humans across the the
land
that we're going to get those
interactions and we're going to get
those human or human violence because in
a dystopian world where it's left to The
Only the strongest survive
uh humans are going to be humans they're
going to turn into their base nature and
they're going to be the enemy the threat
and the overarching threat is the virus
of course but still in you know in the
last of us we all know the human element
is the most dangerous element because
it's more calculating than any fungus
that you know that we can encounter it's
like it is when you look at it like The
Walking Dead you know the the infection
was uh the original thing the zombies
were the original issue but right sooner
or later as human as humans we're going
to solve that issue to some degree maybe
we'll barricade it maybe we'll establish
the society with walls and then at that
point the issue is always going to come
back on us again because every time we
solve an issue in in real life we always
end up bickering at each other because
either we're bored or there's Envy or
like all the emotions come into play at
that point zombies
shine films
um I don't watch
I'm not a huge person in watching
podcasts
and let me explain why
if I did that
then I probably will take on bless you I
would probably take on their thoughts
so I try to avoid it as much as I try to
avoid reviews when I'm reviewing it
exactly so it's another reason why I
tell I don't like people to chew my food
uh when it comes to video games that's
my analogy for that
uh and I and I like to delve deep into
the the subject matter I can watch an
episode three four times uh to come to
some type of thesis and and bring it
across in a manner that um is original
from my words right and also I really
want to have the conversation with Neil
druckman
um about it it with my words so if if it
seems like I'm ignorant to the podcast
it's because
uh so those of you that that are looking
at the chat um you know if you're
walking with the pre I just threw links
we did start r r YouTube channel and the
reason that I'm putting this out there
because I know some of you don't like
watching like I'm probably not going to
do time stamps on this and the reason
I'm not going to do time stamps is
because we're gonna upload the
individual segments that make sense onto
that channel so uh you know The Last of
Us Part Two is going to go on there
we're probably going to put uh there's a
Megan one already on there you know
we're putting the spoiler Castle on that
channel and then sooner or later I do
want to evolve that into more but right
now that's all it is and uh that that's
that's what I'm putting on there but you
know let's get into it King let's let's
go over there and sub to that channel
chat the 63 people I want 63 Subs by the
end of the show
pursue all right so
what would you give this episode man
popcorns man I need some popcorns from
you it's it's a full popcorn because
I got a chance to see
Neil's Style
in in directing
um and that's what I that's that's all I
wanted you know um I believe he's a dope
uh game designer I believe he's a
fantastic story writer
I just wanted to see him direct the the
live film and and he did so and he
mastered class I think all the shots was
done uh well like when it was outside
the wall you know
um when he went inside and Ellie was so
happy to go inside a posh Hotel
and she she's a kid man and that came
across she's a kid
and
she she's happy to be outside you can
see the wonderment in her eyes and they
changed in the first episode remember
when she got out she she stood up
knowing that there was mad danger going
on she's like oh my God I'm outside so
you know I do like you know I'm
but
the actual casting start no you know
it's it's especially with Ellie Skinner
you'd be used to it but she's growing on
me she's growing on me
um you're gonna be surprised King you're
gonna be surprised I'm gonna give this a
five five popcorn
um well Okay
the reason I want to give it a five
popcorn why is because they did the
clicker so well oh yeah it's just I feel
like
Last of Us the clickers is what makes
the whole the entire lore of Last of Us
act like unique there's not really
anything like the clickers and all of
gaming and TV and movies and everything
it's they did a good job explaining the
clickers without explaining yeah they
did a good job like because when you
went up there and they were on the side
and and Ellie was like panicking and job
was like
like like he told her
silently
they can't they can't hear they can't
see but they can hear yeah and they just
it did it was so well like look do I got
issues with the lack of humans yet uh
but at the end of the day uh you know
there's still plenty of plenty of time
to show us human atmosphere uh it's it's
just it's a good show you know I I don't
agree with Tyler that it's like the best
show on right now I think there's still
shows that I would have to um I actually
I think uh the Chucky TV show just ended
so it's definitely probably up there you
know it's probably up there but you know
the turkey TV show yeah after I finished
uh uh sick it flipped right into the
Chucky episode right and I'm sitting
there like what the hell is going on I
thought it was a a end credit scene but
it was a Chucky doll so I had to you
know just sidebar so okay so you give it
five I give it four
um because I think that there's going to
be an episode that's going to blow me
away and
I believe that the clickers they showed
how dangerous that they were but they
did Ellie did ask
is it ones that shoot out spores that
explode on you That Shoot Out Sports
because I heard about that
so they are gonna have the bloaters in
here and so right they're gonna have to
bloat it there
and I just the reason I'm personally
giving this a perfect score and is
because they just they did such a good
job on them clickers man and I was
worried about it because I was worried
they weren't going to get the they would
get the appearance right but not the
noise or right
but not the appearance but they hit them
both they made them terrifying like the
whole time me and Grace were watching
she's like oh my God like it was so well
done they did that now obviously in the
game the clickers grab you as a rat yeah
that's a game they do that for gameplay
mechanics that's not really probably how
that would work out
oh
I know I saw people clowning on it like
they grabbed them a couple of times it's
like in a game it would have been game I
saw BG post man they must be playing on
easy mode because he grabbed them like
four times yeah but it was funny man it
was well done I thought that Aesthetics
is like I said the atmosphere is
incredible apparently Gene said this
next episode episode three is the best
episode of see that's why I can't give
it a a five yet until until I get to
that episode that makes me call you on
the phone I guess I guess the reason I I
usually write stuff differently I write
on what that episode was achieving that
episode was about the clickers so they
did the clickers right they did this the
sound appearance right they did the
build up to it right I can't
realistically find anything wrong with
that episode besides maybe lack of human
interaction and human atmosphere so
there's nothing I can give it a fourth
because of you know what I'm gonna tell
you I feel you I just hold that popcorn
very high so if I'm gonna give you a
five maybe you're gonna have to knock my
socks off so I mean it was it was
I just if I probably didn't have that
question with the kiss it would have
probably been a five so um I still have
that question with the kiss so that's
about it but other than that it's just
dope
one through five man give us your
popcorns one through four yeah let me
let's see Chad talk to me
I'm curious opinion my wife texted me
because she watching she's like tell
them it had me hiding on top of you like
I'm watching and she's on my side and
she's tucked under my arm watching and
when the clickers came out because I
know they're coming out she has no idea
well see grace played enough where she
knew what the clickers were but she
didn't know how vicious they could be
you know what I'm saying my wife never
played this so she's watching this with
brand new eyes
and she was like what the actual you
know and you know it's it's dope it's
just dope
they did a good job man they did a good
job I agree with you of course you guys
would agree with each other
nah a lot of dudes agree with you man
a lot of dudes agree with you five five
five we we we we good man we go the chat
agrees with addicts yeah it's a radical
in this round I mean but we all win we
all win man
all right so that that's enough about
The Last of Us man I'm in that uh that
video so your assignment for next week
is violent night
where the hell is that at I believe
that's on HBO Max
um it's about Santa Claus sir
oh is that the killer killer Santa Claus
just watch it I can't I can't spoil it
for you man
I mean it's cool I'll watch it uh yeah
so that's that's that's my and I'm
pretty sure that you'll come up with
something for me to watch hold up I
actually got him if y'all want you to
watch oh tell me tell me sir
uh it's called
okay I'm probably gonna butcher this
name if I try to pronounce it it's an
old movie it's a made in 2001. uh I
don't know if you've played if you've
played this movie I'm gonna put it in
the chat
have you ever watched that movie what is
it uh Frailty yes
I don't think so I'll check it out yeah
it's it's pretty much about a dude his
brother is a serial killer and they're
trying to figure it out and he's trying
to help the cops find him if I remember
correctly uh so
I think what we need to do from now on
is chat you know the movie I'm watching
you know the movie he's watching
obviously he's going to continue his
last of us thing uh his Attack on Titan
thing we're gonna have General ideal
we're going to be watching uh Last of Us
episode three uh you know you guys know
what worldwide yeah yeah Matthew
McConaughey's in it uh you guys are you
talking about uh you guys should watch
the sadness
yeah Frailty is fire we're going to
um we're going to start posting this
stuff up uh I gotta get a poll out I
want them to know what we're watching so
they can watch it throughout this week
because I think if we do pick something
in the middle of the week we need to
tweet about it we need to show this is
what we're going to be watching because
I I do understand people coming into the
show watching us talk about sick for 20
minutes and they're like dude I want I
want to hear what you guys have to say
but now I don't even know what this
movie is you guys didn't talk about it
last week so we'll do better on
communicating with you guys because we
want to make sure that when we talk
about these you guys can watch you guys
can experience it with us because you've
seen the movie yeah and if you don't
watch a movie it's your fault so yeah so
that that way y'all y'all can be uh a
little bit more connected to us when it
comes to that in that regard so tonight
I'll probably watch Realty if I'm not
gonna watch a couple of episodes Attack
on Titan you can watch that with your
wife that is a good couples movie well
listen she's watching she's watching
Attack on Titan with me
this is that's she's so invested in
Attack on Titan
once you saw the female Titan she's like
oh oh
yo that ain't nothing doing nothing
about the dude here cause we thought he
died and um she grabbed him up and she
squished it looked like she squished his
head and blood popped out but nah he
don't die that easy he popped out of
hand blew her hand up I said this is my
man I like that dude so yeah so that
that is right
um like I said we are redoing how like
the patreon and stuff is you know um
probably when King hits the forest and
Attack on Titan he's probably gonna have
to start uh live reacting to that uh
we'll figure out a way to have it set up
pretty good even if we have to use like
a GoPro and a stand so he can watch it
comfortably somewhere else I don't know
but we'll figure it out but yo listen
listen guys also don't forget the road
to PAX East is on
um I don't know what we're gonna do
we'll probably catch me and addict going
to a movie watching a movie while we out
there whatever for R R I have no idea
we're going to figure it out but the
road to PAX East is there our goal is
still up there so anything you guys
contribute to this show
podcast definitely goes to the road to
PAX East all right so yeah because all
the super chats is still all it does is
you know we're gonna get the AMC like
month pass theme because oh yeah we want
to give you guys plenty of content and I
think the way to grow the brand is to
watch current stuff with the old stuff
so yeah as long as we constantly have
that newer products going out there on
this new channel and talking about here
on this channel we'll be able to grow
both channels to a sizable amount and
then once we get to a certain point that
we can start getting early screenings we
can give you guys our opinions before
the movie comes out so you don't go
watch blind stuff man so you know
exactly going blind it's good because
you know starting next month uh you know
February uh attic and I is gonna we're
gonna join that program the MC program
uh where we get a chance to watch all
those movies and uh yeah we're gonna go
sit down we're gonna go watch these
movies and we're gonna come uh with uh
current stuff very very current stuff
that's inside the movies along with this
uh these episodes of The Last of Us
which are phenomenal so got a ton of
movies this year bro yeah we got a lot
settled for you so I'ma watch what's
that movie called
oh you're gonna watch a violent night
violent night okay all right I'm gonna
put that in the chat right now all right
and Frailty is what I'm going to watch
uh I can't I think frailty's on HBO Max
too I'll figure it out I'll find it
Frailty and violent night
yes sir
all right all right so we'll see you
guys next week now keep in mind tomorrow
we're going to be reacting to the uh
Xbox show tickets
3 P.M so definitely uh tune into that
and then uh Wednesday the attic show and
then Sunday we'll be back for another
episode of iron Lords podcast appreciate
it for coming through definitely go go
to that man go to that YouTube channel I
put in the Des in the uh the thing uh
because we we definitely want to get
that as high as we can
um you know I haven't really promoted it
too much because I want to get the
artwork and stuff at least the logo done
before we do that but you know I'm gonna
put in the chat a couple more times uh
definitely go to that man uh sub to that
that way if if you want something
particular you could just go to that and
watch that particular section of the
video but I appreciate everyone coming
through this is Florida addict and
Kingdom